[Music]
you're a multi-millionaire you're one of
the most successful youtubers in history
how can somebody like me starting off
develop it grow an audience
what are some tips or five moves that we
can apply out there and
and that are aspiring so first of all
let me ask you this how many people have
you interviewed yourself how many people
have you interviewed uh
68 68 okay i i've been interviewed by a
lot of people
your top three best ever that's ever
interviewed and i'm not
you can't well you can't see me say this
to other people so if you go watch
other people that have interviewed me
i've never said this to anybody so i'm
saying this to you
because you're you're gentle you make me
trust you to open up to you and talk to
and it's almost like it's just you and i
even though there's audience that's
watching this the idea of somebody that
can interview has to make me feel
uh very comfortable that i'm speaking to
them you can do that you
are able to do proper research you're
asking questions other people are not
asking
so you're not the conventional mercy
yeah i mean i'm mercy mercy mercy yes
you are welcome
so that's very impressive